>>Suzanne Reeves: If I was to imagine
creating a school from scratch,
I would look at "What am I
preparing my students for?
What is this world that
they're gonna be going into?"
and "how can I make their experience
in school feel more close
to that outside world?
How do I sort of turn
the school inside out?"
>>Adrienne Curtis Dickinson:
We are in the process
of re-designing thirty courses, which
affects nearly seventy-five teachers.
This is not easy, we're engaged
in work that asks teachers
to really examine classroom practices
that have been things they've done
for a really long time,
and so helping teachers
to re-define curriculum is a
really challenging mental shift.
>>Suzanne Reeves: So
we're really focused
on giving students a problem-based
experience across the whole school
and we've had to think about
"How does that really look?"
and "how does it apply?"
There are places where
it's less intuitive
and where it's a little
bit more challenging.
English and math are ones
where people don't think
about problem-based learning.
>>Danielle Lynch: I was very unsure,
I didn't know, "What does this look
like in a math classroom?"
I think overall that there's
a little bit of apprehension,
just when you're talking about
doing something completely new.
It's really exciting to see all
students engaged in your class,
and I think that the
difference of having PBL
in classrooms really is helping
overall engage our students.
>>Alicia Kallay: I think
there have been varying levels
of acceptance of PBL.
What I think has worked
for teachers to buy
in to PBL is having teachers
create their own courses
by giving them the voice and
also giving them this time to try
to figure out what it looks like
within their own subject area.
>>I think we really struggled to find
a way to inject PBL into English.
We didn't want the study
of literature to be lost.
I don't want to lose
what inspires people.
For literature it is harder
because the authentic
problems are these really big
philosophical questions.
Being able to see what
else students could do
and moving beyond the
traditional essay
that follows reading,
it was a challenge.
>>Suzanne Reeves: One starting point
for all the courses is thinking
about what professionals in this
discipline really do and then say,
"How do we give students
more of that experience?"
>>Alicia Kallay: Before,
it was all about the text,
but I feel like now it's about
them engaging with the text
in a different way,
and it's engaging them
with a text as a writer themselves.
A book that students read is Eli
Wiesel's Holocaust memoir "Night,"
as they're reading they're
seeing what are the consequences
of remaining silent.
We ask them to start to look
for groups or individuals
who are silenced in some way
and, like Eli Wiesel is doing,
is give voice to a
voiceless population.
So what you're actually asking
them to do is apply the themes
that they've seen in
the text themselves.
>>Emma: I think using PBL in English
classes, or in any other class,
really kind of changes your
perspective on what that subject is
and what that subject entails.
You really see how the subjects
you're learning at fifteen years old,
how you can use them for your future
and for the rest of your life.
>>Teacher: Making a tool
would be to have a--
>>Danielle Lynch: Our
leadership team said,
"We don't know what this
looks like for math.
You guys need to, by trial and error,
figure out what does it look like?
What's gonna work best?"
I think each group of
teachers that works together
to design functions a
little bit differently.
We wanted to be able to not
lose any content in our course
and still really enrich it
with problems or projects.
We don't have a PBL-based
unit for every concept
that we teach in Algebra 2.
We really just looked at
where it fits and I think
that is our best approach in math.
>>Suzanne Reeves: This problem-based
learning isn't gonna look the same
in every class and so if we're just
trying to kind of shoehorn the way
that we teach into this kind
of mold that we think is trendy
or that we think we're supposed to do
because the administration told us,
then, yeah, it won't work.
>>Danielle Lynch: Well, I think that
the idea of problem-based learning is
to engage those students who normally
in a traditional math
classroom wouldn't be engaged.
So one example is in our probability
unit: We have students create games.
For students who may not be pro-math,
math may not be their favorite
subject, I think when they think
about "Okay, I have free rein to
create a game," that's something
that can kind of hook
them into the unit.
Then you can connect
that saying, "Okay,
how can we find the
probability of what you created?"
>>Angelo: The project helps
me, like, to be focused more.
Making the game project
it's fun and then there's,
like, a connection to it.
It makes me more engaged
through math.
>>Teacher: Do your best
to work around that.
>>Adrienne Curtis Dickinson:
I am so excited
about the progress at Sammamish.
We have really seen some enormous
outcomes for our students already.
>>All of that is coming through the
hard work our teachers are doing.
>>Suzanne Reeves: It's exciting
professionally to be pushed,
to have the opportunity
to collaborate
with colleagues in a new way.
>>Danielle Lynch: It's like anything.
You have days where you
can get a lot accomplished.
There're days where you feel
stuck, but we're working together,
we're a team we're all working
towards the same goal of learning.